No,
I'm going to ask you this question.
Why are you here?
That is to say,
why should you,
we all of us want to study
these ancient Greeks.
I think it's reasonable for people who
are considering the study of a particular
subject in a college course
to ask why they should.
What is it about the ancient Greeks
between the years that I mentioned to you
that deserves the attention
of people in the 21st century?
I think the answer is to be
found or at least one answer.
The truth is,
there are many answers into some of
them is it's just terribly interesting,
but that's very much of a, uh, uh,
what's the word I want
the opposite of objective,
subjective observation by me.
So I would say a less objective one is
that I believe that it comes from their
position that is to stay the
position of the Greeks at the most,
the most significant starting
point of Western civilization,
which is the culture that most
powerfully shapes not only the west,
but most of the world today.
It seems to me be the evidence that
whatever it's other characteristics.
The West has created institutions
of government and law that provide
unprecedented freedom for its people.
It's also invented a body of natural
scientific knowledge and technological
achievement that together make
possible a level of health and material
prosperity undreamed of in earlier times
and unknown outside the West and those
places that have been
influenced by the West.
I think the Nobel Prize
Laureate v as Nepal,
a man born in Trinidad of Indian parents
was right when he spoke of the modern
world as our universal civilisation
shaped chiefly by the West.
Most people around the world who
know of them want to benefit from the
achievements of western
science and technology.
Many of them also want to
participate in its political freedom.
Moreover,
experienced suggests that a society cannot
achieve the full benefits of western
science and technology without a
commitment to reason and objectivity as
essential to knowledge and
to the political freedom
that sustains it and helps
it to move forward.
The primacy reason and the
pursuit of objectivity.
Therefore both characteristic of the
Western experience seemed to me to be
essential for the achievement
of the desired goals almost
anywhere in the world.
The civilization of the West,
however,
was not the result of some inevitable
process through which other cultures will
automatically pass.
It emerged from a unique history in
which chance and accidents often played a
vital part.
The institutions and the ideas
therefore that provide for freedom and
improvement in the material conditions
of life cannot take root and flourish
without an understanding of how they
came about and what challenges they have
had to surmount.
Nonwestern peoples who wish to share and
the things that characterize modernity.
We'll need to study the ideas and history
of Western civilization to achieve
what they want and westerners,
I would argue,
who wished to preserve these
things must do the same.
The many civilizations adopted by
the human race have shared basic
characteristics.
Most have tended toward cultural
uniformity and stability reason.
Although it was employed for all sorts
of practical and intellectual purposes in
some of these cultures,
it still lacked independence from
religion and it lacked the high status to
challenge the most basic received ideas.
Standard form of government has
been monarchy outside the west.
Republics have been unknown.
Rulers have been thought to be divine
or appointed spokesmen for divinity.
Religious and political institutions
and beliefs have been thoroughly
intertwined as a mutually supportive,
unified structure.
Government has not been subject
to secular reasoned analysis.
It has rested on religious authority,
tradition and power.
The concept of individual freedom
has had no importance in these,
uh, the great majority of
cultures of in human history.
The first and the sharpest break with
this common human experience came in
ancient Greece.
The Greek city states called
police were republics.
Differences in wealth among their
citizens were relatively small.
There were no kings with the
wealth to hire mercenary soldiers.
So the citizens had to do their own
fighting and to decide when to fight as
independent defenders of the common
safety and the common interest.
They demanded a role in the most
important political decisions in this way.
For the first time political
life really was invented,
observed that the word political
derives from the Greek word Polis.
Before that no word was needed
because there was no such thing.
This political life came to be shared
by a relatively large portion of the
people and participation in political
life was highly valued by the Greeks.
Such states of course did not
need a bureaucracy for their one,
no vast royal or state holdings that
needed management and not much economic
surplus to support a bureaucratic class.
There was no separate cast of priests
and there was very little concern.
I don't mean no concern, but very
little concern with life after death,
which was universally important than other
civilizations in this varied dynamic,
secular and remarkably free context.
There are rose for the first time a
speculative natural philosophy based on
observation and reason.
The roots of modern natural science and
philosophy free to investigate or to
ignore divinity.
What most sets the Greeks apart is their
view of the world where other people's
have seen sameness and continuity.
The Greeks and the heirs
have their way of thinking,
have tended to notice disjunctions
and to make distinctions.
The Greek way of looking
at things requires a change
from the characteristic way
of knowing things before the Greeks.
That is to say the use of faith,
poetry and intuition,
and instead,
increasingly the Greeks focused
on a reliance on reason,
reason,
permits,
a continuing rational inquiry
into the nature of reality.
Unlike mystical insights,
scientific theories can not be
arrived at by meditation alone,
but require accurate observation of the
world and reasoning of a kind that other
human beings can
criticize, analyze, modify,
and correct.
The adoption of this way of thinking
was the beginning of the liberation and
enthronement of reason to WHO's searching.
Examination,
the Greeks thereafter exposed
everything they perceived natural,
human and divine
from the top,
from the time they formed their republics,
until they were conquered
by alien empires.
The Greeks also rejected
monarchy of any kind.
They thought that a human
being functioning in his
full capacity must live as a
free man in an autonomous Polis ruled
by laws that were the product of the
political community and not have an
arbitrary Fiat from some man or God.
These are ideas about laws and justice
that have simply not flourished outside
the western tradition,
uh,
until places where that were
outside the western tradition.
We're influenced by the
West. The Greeks, however,
combined a unique sense of mankind's
high place in the natural order.
The Greeks had the most arrogant view of
their relationship to the divinity is I
will tell you about later in
the course of any people I know.
So on the one hand, they had this very
high picture of this place of mad,
but they combined it,
excuse me,
and what possibilities human
beings head before that.
And they combined it with a painful
understanding of the limitations of the
greatness and the Paul,
the possibilities before Matt.
This combination of elevating the
greatness in reality and in possibility of
human beings with the limitations of it.
One,
the greatest limitation being mortality
that together composes the tragic vision
of the human condition that characterized
classical Greek civilization to cope
with it.
They urged human beings to restrain
their overarching ambitions inscribed at
Apollo's temple at Delphi,
which became,
well the Greeks came to call
it the navel of the universe,
but it certainly became the center of the
Greek world and which was also seen as
a central place of importance
by non Greeks who were on
the borders of the Greek
world, uh, that that temple of
Delphi had written above the temple.
These words know thyself
and another statement,
nothing in excess.
I think those together really mean this.
Know your own limitations as a fallible
mortal and then exercise moderation
because you are not divine.
You are mortal beyond these exhortations.
They relied on a good political regime
to enable human beings to fulfill the
capacities that was part of that.
We're part of their nature to train
them in virtue and to restrain them from
vice Aristotle and his politics made the
point neatly and I quote him as a man,
I'm sorry, as man is the best
of the animals. Went perfected,
so he is the worst when separated from
law and justice for injustice is most
dangerous when it is armed and man armed
by nature with good sense and virtue
may use them for entirely opposite ends.
Therefore,
if when he is without virtue,
man is the most unscrupulous
and savage of the animals
are went on to say that the justice
needed to control this dark side of human
nature can be found only in a well
ordered society of free people who govern
themselves and the only one that he
knew was the polis of the Greeks.
Now the second great strand in the
history of the West is the Judeo Christian
tradition.
A very different tradition from
the one I've just described.
Christianity's main routes where in
Judaism a religion that worshiped a single
all powerful deity who is
sharply separated from human
beings makes great moral
demands upon them and judges them all.
Even kings and emperors.
Christianity began as a
persecuted religion that
ultimately captured the Roman
empire only after centuries of
hostility towards the empire,
towards Rome,
towards the secular state in general,
and it never lost entirely.
It's original character as an insurgent
movement independent of the state and
hostile to it, making claims that
challenged the secular authority.
This too is unique to the west,
just like the Greek experiences unique.
This kind of religious organization
is to be found nowhere else in human
society.
So the Union of a universalist religion
with a monarch such as the Roman empire,
who ruled a vast empire,
could nonetheless have put an end to
any prospect of freedom as in other
civilizations.
But Christianity's inheritance of the
rational disputatious Greek philosophy led
to powerfully divisive about the nature
of God and other theological questions,
which was perfectly in the tradition
and uniquely in the tradition of Greek
philosophical debate.
What I'm doing is making a claim that
even the Judeo Christian tradition,
which is such a different one from the
Greeks and in so many ways seems to be at
odds with it,
even though they were dependent upon
one aspect of the Greek culture,
which is inherent in Christianity
and important and Christianity,
uh,
that too was ultimately a Greek source.
Well,
the people whom the Romans
called barbarians destroy
the western empire and it
also destroyed the power of the emperors
and their efforts to impose religious
and political conformity
under imperial control.
The emperor in the east was able to do
that because they were not conquered by
the barbarians.
But in the West you have this situation
where nobody is fully in charge.
And here we have arrived at a second
sharp break with the general experience of
mankind,
the west of the Germanic tribes that had
toppled the Roman empire was weak and
under,
and it was divided.
The barriers to unity presented by
European geography and very limited
technology made it hard for would be
conqueror to create a vast empire,
eliminating competitors and
imposing his will over vast areas.
These conditions permitted the development
of institutions and habits needed for
free freedom,
even as they also made Europe vulnerable
to conquest and to extinction and
Europe was almost extinguished
practically before there was a Europe.
Very early in its history.
The Christian Church might have stepped
into the Breech and imposed obedience
and uniformity because
before terribly long,
all of the West had been Christianized,
but the church in fact never gained
enough power to control the state strong
enough to interfere with the
ambitions of emperors and kings.
It never was able to
impose its own domination.
Though some of the pope's short try,
nobody sought or plan for freedom,
but in the spaces that will left by the
endless conflicts among secular rulers
and between them and the church,
there was room for freedom to grow.
Freedom was the kind of an accident it
came about because the usual ways of
doing things were not possible
into some of that space.
Towns and cities reappeared and
with them new supports for freedom,
taking advantage of the
rivalries I've mentioned.
They obtained charters from the local
powers establishing their rights to
conduct their own affairs and
to govern themselves in Italy.
Some of these cities were able to gain
control of the surrounding country and to
become city states resembling
those of the ancient Greeks.
Their autonomy was assisted by the
continuing struggle between popes and
emperors, between Church and state. Again,
a thoroughly unique western
experience in these states,
the modern world began to take form,
although the people
were mainly Christians,
they are life and outlook
became increasingly secular
here and not only in Italy
but in other cities.
North of the Alps arose a worldview that
celebrated the greatness and dignity of
mankind,
which was a very sharp turning away from
the medieval western tradition that put
God and life in the hereafter.
At the center of everything,
this New Vision is revealed with Flamboyan
confidence by Pico della Mirando,
la of Florentine thinker who said,
uh,
wrote the following,
God told man that we meaning God
have made thee neither of Heaven,
nor of earth,
neither mortal nor immortal.
So that with freedom of choice and with
honor as though the maker and molder of
thyself,
thou mayest fashion by myself in
whatever shape thou shalt prefer.
Oh su-preme generosity of God,
the father oh highest and the
most great Felicity of man.
To him,
it is granted to have whatever he
chooses to be whatever he wills.
Now,
this is a remarkable leap even
beyond the humanism of the Greeks.
Something brand new in the world according
to this view of man is not merely the
measure of all things as the Greek sophos
Protagoras had radically proclaimed in
the fifth century.
He is in fact says Pico more than mortal.
He is unlimited by nature.
He is entirely free to shape himself
and to acquire whatever he wants.
Please observe too that it is not his
reason that will determine human actions,
but his will alone free of the
moderating control of reason.
Another Florentine Machiavelli moved
further in the same direction for him,
and I quote him.
Fortune is a woman and it is necessary
to hold her down and beat her and site
with her.
A notion that the Greeks,
whatever regarded as dangerously
arrogant and certain to produce disaster,
it would have seen this as an example
of the word that they use and we'll talk
about a lot in this course.
Hubris is kind of violent arrogance
which comes upon men when they see
themselves as more than human and
behave as though they were divine.
Francis Bacon influenced by Machiavelli
urged human beings to employ their
reason to force nature to give up its
secrets to treat nature like a woman to
master nature in order to
improve man's material wellbeing.
He assumed that such a course with lead
to progress and the general improvement
of the human condition,
and it was that sort of thinking that
lay at the heart of the scientific
revolution and remains the faith on
which modern science and technology rest.
A couple of other English
political philosophers,
Hobbes and Locke applied a similar
novelty and maternity to the sphere of
politics.
Basing their understanding on the common
passions of men for a comfortable self
preservation and discovering something
the Greeks had never thought of,
something they called natural rights
that belonged to a man either as part of
nature or as the gift of a
benevolent and reasonable God.
Man was seen as a solitary creature,
not inherently a part of society that's
totally on Greek and his basic rights
were seen to be absolute for nothing,
must interfere with the right of
each individual to defend his life.
Liberty and property freedom was
threatened in early modern times by the
merchants of monarchies that
might have been able to crush it.
But the cause of individual freedom was
enhanced by the Protestant reformation.
Another upheaval within Christianity
arising from its focus on individual
salvation.
It's inheritance of a
tradition of penetrating reason
applied even to matters of
faith and to the continuing
struggle between church and state.
The English revolution came about in
large part because of King Charles the
first attempt to impose an alien
religious conformity as well as tighter
political control on his kingdom.
In England,
the tradition of freedom and government
bound by law was already strong enough
to produce effective resistance from
the ensuing rebellion came limited
constitutional representative government
and ultimately our modern form of
democracy.
The example and the idea is that produced,
encouraged and informed the French and
the American revolutions and the entire
modern constitutional tradition.
These ideas and institutions are the
basis for modern liberal thinking about
politics,
the individual and society.
Just as the confident view of science
and technology as progressive forces
improving the lot of
humanity and increasing man's
capacity to understand and
control the universe has been the most
powerful form taken by the Western
elevation of reason in
the last two centuries.
Both these most characteristic elements
of western civilization have in fact
become increasingly under heavy
attack at different times,
science and technology have been blamed
for the destruction of human community
and the alienation of people from nature
and from one another for intensifying
the gulf between rich and poor,
for threatening the very
existence of humanity,
either by producing weapons of total
destruction or by destroying the
environment.
At the same time,
the foundations of freedom
have also come into question.
Jefferson and his colleagues
could confidently proclaim
their political rights
as being self evident and
the gift of a creator.
By now in our time,
however,
the power of religion
has faded and for many,
the basis of modern political and
moral order has been demolished.
Nicha announced the death of God and
dusty Yefsky is grand inquisitor asserted
that when God is dead,
all things are permitted.
Nihilism,
rejects any objective basis
for society and it's morality.
It rejects the very concept of objectivity
and even rejects the possibility of
communication itself.
And a Volvo form of nihilism I claim
has a remarkable influence in our
educational system today.
Uh,
the system rotting from the head
down so chiefly in universities,
but all the way down
to elementary schools.
The consequences of the
victory of such ideas,
I believe would be enormous.
If both religion and reason are removed,
all that remains is will and power.
We're,
the only law is the law of tooth and claw.
There is no protection for the freedom
of weaker individuals or those who
questioned the authority
of the most powerful.
There is no basis for individual rights
or for a critique of existing ideas and
institutions.
If there is no base either
in religion or reason,
that's such a tax on the greatest
achievements of the West should be made by
western intellectuals,
is perfectly in keeping
with the western tradition,
the first crowd to do stuff like that.
You will find in the fifth century
BC in Greece in a movement called the
sophistic movement.
These sophos raised most of the questions
that my colleagues are now spending
all their time with now.
Yet to me,
it seems ironic that they have
gained so much currency in a time,
more or less,
uh,
in which the achievements
of Western reason, uh,
and in the form of ancient
form of science and uh,
and at a moment when it's concept of
political freedom seem to be more popular
and more desirable to people in and
out of Western civilization than ever.
Now, I've been saying kind things
about Western civilization,
but I would not want to deny that there
is a dark side to the western experience
and its way of life to put untrammeled
reason and individual freedom at the
center of a civilization is to live
with the conflict that turmoil,
the instability and the uncertainty
that these things create.
Freedom was born and has survived in the
space created by divisions and conflict
within and between nations and religions.
We must wonder whether the power of
modern weapons will allow it and the world
to survive at such a price
individual freedom,
although it has greatly elevated the
condition of the people who have lived in
free societies inevitably
permits inequalities,
which are the more galling because each
person is plainly free to try to improve
his situation and largely
responsible for the outcome.
Freedom does,
does permit isolation from society and
an alienation of the individual at a high
cost both to the individual and society.
And these are not the only problems posed
by the western tradition in its modern
form,
which is what we live in.
Whether it takes the shape of the
unbridled claims of Pico della Mirando,
La of the Nietzschean associate,
uh,
assertion of the power of the superior
individual to transform and shape his own
nature or of the modern totalitarian
effort to change the nature of humanity by
Utopian social engineer.
The temptation to arrogance offered by
the ideas and worldly success of the
modern west threatens its own
great traditions and achievements
because of Western civilizations,
emergence as the eggs and
[inaudible] civilization.
It also presents problems
to the whole world.
The challenges presented by freedom and
the predominance of reason cannot be
ignored.
No.
Can they be met by recourse to the
experience of other cultures where these
characteristics have not been prominent?
In other words,
to understand and cope with
the problems that we all face,
we all need to know and to grapple
with the Western experience.
In my view,
we need especially to examine
the older traditions of the West.
It came to for the modern era and to take
seriously the possibility that useful
wisdom can be found there,
especially among the
Greeks who began at all.
They understood the
potentiality of human beings.
They are limitations and the
predicament in which they live.
Man is potent and important.
Yet he is fallible and mortal capable of
the greatest achievements and the worst
crimes.
He is then a tragic figure,
powerful but limited with
freedom to choose an act,
but bound by his own nature,
knowing that he will never achieve perfect
knowledge and understanding justice
and happiness, but determined to
continue the search no matter what.
To me that seems an accurate description
of the human condition that is
meaningful, not only for the
Greeks and their heirs in the west,
but for all human beings.
It is an understanding that cannot be
achieved without a serious examination of
the western experience.
The abandonment of such a study or
it's adulteration for current political
purposes would be a terrible loss
for all of humanity and at the base,
at the root of that
civilization stood the grapes.
These are the reasons why I examined
their experience and I trust why you are
thinking about learning about
it. Thank you. I'll see you guys.
Some of you next Tuesday.